j'envoie une carte ancienne de 2 many
d'accord découvrir ou redécouvrir magny
les hameaux à travers une pièce de
théâtre le principe de j'habite à
manille un spectacle créé à partir du
témoignage des habitants
après une première édition à trappes
catherine nayl metteur en scène est
parti à la rencontre des manic moi je
les fais témoigné je leur demande
d'abord pourquoi ils habitent cette
ville depuis combien de temps et
d'audition et qu'est ce qu'ils y font
et à partir de là on essaie de composer
un spectacle à partir des anecdotes à
partir de leurs ressentis à partir de
leurs émotions
depuis novembre 2018 il travaille sur
cette représentation
dix participants des manic wade many
cases des jeunes des adultes
tous ont quelque chose en eux de manille
j'avais envie de j'aime bien théâtre
déjà et j'avais envie de découvrir un
autre monde du théâtre c'est à dire on
raconte notre vie et on joue par un
personnage on la raconte la vie
d'habitants de magny les hameaux ont
fait découvrir au public lors du
spectacle comme on y vit comme on y
habite qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire là bas
magnette une ville très très très
dynamique qu'il y à beaucoup de choses
et que des fois les gens ne le savent
pas toujours qu'il ya tout ça moi j'y
raconte donc pourquoi j'ai eu
pourquoi je nuis vivre comment ça s'est
passé et puis aussi je raconte des
petites anecdotes dont une une anecdote
bas sur le sur le maire de magny les
hameaux
cinq sont du bisso vous vous installez
ok je baisse la musique tu dis le
buisson et tout lui sont répond en force
en venant voir ce spectacle on découvre
aussi comment vivent les habitants et
c'est important c'est un patrimoine
vivant pour moi je leur disais il ya un
centre à magny les hameaux n'y a pas de
centre mais en fait le centre c'est eux
c'est le coeur et c'est un peu là dessus
que j'ai bâtie la thématique du
spectacle le coeur de magny les hameaux
ce sont ses habitants
prochain projet en cours d'élaboration
avec le musée de la ville j'habite
hashtags saint quentin en yvelines
des témoignages sur les douze communes
avec des comédiens et des habitants